the snows of winter evaporate into the  mists of spring  and the shadowy Bobcat emerges with an  apprentice killer in tow mother is an  old hand at this the kitten mirrors her  every move the Huntress demonstrates the  finer points  watch for the tiniest tremor listen for  the slightest scritching and pounce  [Music]  that the vols sometimes getaway is part  of the education if at first you don't  succeed try try again  there you go  mobs kill leads to a rousing game of  keep-away  this sharpens the youngsters ability to  chase and while her kitten needs perhaps  mom will find her own lunch but no  there's another kitten waiting in the  wings  [Music]  and the merry-go-round starts all over  it  [Music]  kids sometimes it seems like they'll  never leave home  [Music]